saturday thousands of americans headed
to dc in support of president trump
this peaceful sea of flags made them an
easy target for thugs who attacked the
non-violent
even chucking fireworks at restaurant
fireworks
diners
after most law-abiding marchers left the
rally thugs descended on stragglers an
elderly couple was attacked children
were terrified
people beaten their belongings ripped
from them
among the attackers a child sex offender
and a journalism student
well at least the left's tent is a big
one these videos ended up only on
twitter the media ignored them saying
they left out context
so what's the context that justifies
beating up innocent people
that they disagreed with the thugs who
the media defend
remember trump is hitler so violence is
accepted the ap's report suggests trump
supporters were the perps
because you know they support trump in
2016 after trump won
thousands hit the street in protest and
they never really left
did anyone harass them of course not we
don't do that
the media glorified those marches
claiming that aside from the riots they
were mostly non-violent
now they're lying again because they
think you deserve it but of maiming
trump supporters is how they react after
they believe they won
what have they thought they lost that's
easy cities would have burned people
would have died
hence the boarded up buildings the fact
that the media ignores
all of this reveals their complicity
while blacklisting people like you and
me
but denying what is obvious is the game
which is why the media sticks their
collective heads in the sand
that leaves their butts in the air and
on camera
so dagon i think we've learned is that
not all victims are created equal you
can hit a trump supporter
oh yeah and it's the dehumanization and
the demonization of trump supporters and
even conservatives
and i don't think this happened over
four years this has been happening
in university classrooms this has been
happening by the media
so when somebody on the left antifa
whatever you want to call them
sees a trump supporter they don't see a
mom or a dad
or a son or a daughter they just see the
enemy they see
the racist the bigot the nazi and
their their means justify
the end justifies the means that they're
pushing and it's violence and i don't
know how you
reverse that it needs to be a collective
push
by everybody who wears a microphone by
everybody in the educational system
to basically i don't know unity yeah
that's so that's the word healing
healing so by definition shouldn't
punch punching somebody over a political
belief be seen as a hate crime
isn't that a hate crime yeah i don't
think it should do that i condemn
violence of all kinds coming from all
directions
but i think taking snippets and i think
this is the problem here is
you take a snippet of an incident and
you don't explain to people what
happened before or after that's what
they mean by context
and if somebody is provoking somebody or
somebody hits somebody and then you have
a snippet of video and you say oh
that look that person were they provoked
misrepresented that doesn't tell you the
truth and i think that's why a lot of
papers and and tv stations say we don't
have the whole story or
in the case of ap that you mentioned ap
said these people had fact been provoked
so
you got to check you got to check out i
think what happened in order to have a
clear
sense non-biases of what happened but i
do think that you have people on both
sides who were being
provocateurs in that situation those
families the proud boys were out there
screaming at people the old that elderly
couple
people sitting at the restaurant they're
eating that breast of chicken in a
profit of a provocative way
no i can't imagine being at a restaurant
eating
outside as you're supposed to do because
indoor dining is not as safe
yeah and then all of a sudden
firecrackers going off like i don't
think i'd ever recover well you don't
like noise anyway
i was terrified of noise yeah i don't
like noise what's the solution here dana
to noise no general life i see
you're dressed in white i see you as an
expert oh yes thank you very much um
you know part of it is i think that um
relatively speaking there were a lot of
peaceful there was a lot of peaceful
marching that went on
um the trump folks that got down there
for the mega march like
that it was it was that was actually
mostly peaceful yes
that you had the violence and we do
amplify it right because you
play it and you see it on social media
but it is happening and
i think one of the things that everybody
has to do and the holiday season might
be a good time to do that especially if
we have to be at home because of the
cover on a virus
you have to think about what kind of
example do you want to lead
and the be the example that you want to
be for your community and for your
family first like start there
rather than nationalizing every issue
but it's like you're talking a language
that
these thugs don't understand they'll
just laugh well that's the other thing i
would actually say um i was going to
recommend uh john podhorus over at
commentary magazine has a piece that
just posted on commentarymagazine.com
in which he talks about how biden and
harris really need
to step up here yeah and and to say
something
obviously going gonna say that trump
does too i get that but that
um biden didn't say anything until today
when he was asked
he could have said something saturday
night that would have maybe you know
helped
jesse last word to you i just found it
funny that juan says the media needs
context
and that the clip might not show the
whole story when does that ever stop the
media yeah
remember the covington boys they went
right out with that one juan
um i think if you're going to fight
fight like a man yeah square up with
someone your own age
that also wants to throw and go yeah but
when i look at these clips and these are
not
30 second clips these are two-minute
three-minute four-minute clips
so and i'm seeing people get sucker
punched from behind right
you see women uh at the elderly getting
attached by
street weapons a journalism student
female punched a woman an elderly woman
in the back of the head
i don't know what context would require
to make that okay and the elderly woman
isn't charging people and biting them
and kicking them
she doesn't want any trouble and it's
what you said and what you said in the
monologue is if you spend four years
telling people that trump and his
supporters are fascists
and nazis and white supremacists that
just gives this mob a license to just
light these people up this is like world
war ii for them again
yeah they feel good about what they're
doing they feel like they're cleaning up
the streets
and if nothing ever happens there's no
penalties then then that's fine if you
say
a maga hat is is an equatable thing to a
swastika
doesn't matter if an old woman or an old
man or a woman is wearing the maga hat
they're dead meat yeah that's what
you're seeing happen